I'm here with Burt vixen who has one  fourth in this Blizzcon cosplay contest  I have to ask what was it like to put  this together I mean this is just  incredible so this is actually a 3d  model by myself and all 3d printed wait  wait wait wait wait I have to share this  I can share this audience I did not well  I sold mine already so I'm not too  worried  I'm here with the second-place winner of  the cosplay contest Ashley and you're  cosplaying as varied red yes she's  always been like McCain kind of thing so  I thought it'd do him justice to cosplay  him  I'm with the winner of the costume  contest Scott who is cosplaying as  Grommash Hellscream I'm just so glad  that you could get out of that amazing  costume because it looked as hot as a  fel fire it was it's very very hot  there's actually insulation but I opted  out for wait I enjoy cosplaying I don't  do professionally but overall yeah this  is more of just a great hobby